the Higgs boson has generated a
firestorm of interest in the media I've
gotten quite a bit of email some people
say that well the Higgs boson wasn't it
overhyped I mean such grand grandiose
claims that we haven't yet nailed it
down well look at it this way we
physicists don't create the news media
people are the ones who massage the news
and put it out to the public we
physicists put out a press release and
hope and pray that somebody picks it up
but 99% of the time let's be real
nothing happens at all so blame the
media if the media hyped up the Higgs
boson too much and the name the god
particle it was a book editor who took a
very ordinary title xed it out and said
no let's call it the god particle and
that's another reason why the media
latched on to this thing now did we
actually find the Higgs boson and the
answer is no we narrowed it down so that
within 95% certainty we know that it's
not in large areas of the the mass
spectrum of the Large Hadron Collider so
sometime in 2012 we think we will
finally bag the Higgs boson and then the
champagne bottles will pop open and
we'll all have a great time the other
emails I get asked the question so what
so what if we get the Higgs boson what
does it mean well remember that after 50
years of smashing atoms ploughing
protons into protons we have now
hundreds of subatomic particles arranged
in what is called the standard model but
there's one piece of the jigsaw puzzle
missing and that last piece is called
the Higgs boson so if we don't find the
Higgs boson we're in deep doo-doo it
means that something is fundamentally
wrong with all of modern physics so most
physicists will believe that yes we will
finally Bank the Higgs boson but then
what look at the standard model let's be
blunt about it the standard model is one
of the ugliest theories ever proposed in
the history of science it's a theory
that only a mother could love
thirty-six quarks and antiquarks 19 or
more free parameters three generations
of redundant particles whole bunches of
gluons and yang-mills particles and W
bosons and C bosons and Higgs bosons I
mean you go crazy trying to make sense
an order out of this ragtag bunch of
subatomic particles called the standard
model so what do we physicists believe
we think there's a higher theory a
higher theory that includes gravity
which is missing in the standard model
plus a standard model only describes 4%
of the matter energy content of the
universe just 4% Dark Matter makes up
23% dark energy makes up 73% so a huge
chunk of the universe is missing and
that's why some of us like myself
believe in something called string
theory string theory the standard model
including the Higgs boson is nothing but
the lowest octave the lowest octave of a
vibrating string and dark matter which
makes up 23% of the universe is nothing
but like the next vibration up the next
octave of the string and then dark
energy well dark energy it takes place
when you break the symmetries of the
super string so string theory is the
only game in town which has the ability
to be really a true theory of everything
so the next step is to try to find dark
matter with the Large Hadron Collider
that could go a long ways toward either
proving or disproving strengthen
you